Now you might be asking, why in the world are we talking about logic?
I mean, certainly it makes sense to talk about faith.
Certainly it makes sense to talk about truth.
But why would we take an entire week out to talk about something so strange in a
Bible
study about logic?
Well,
I think it starts with what the writer of Hebrews says in the last part of chapter
5 and the early part of chapter 6.
So does anyone who lives on milk, still an infant,
is not acquainted with the teaching
about righteousness, but solid food is for the mature,
who by constant use have trained
themselves to distinguish good from evil.
Therefore, let us leave the elementary teachings about Christ and go on to maturity.
Peter says much the same thing about leaving the idea of spiritual milk and moving
on
to maturity.
Paul says,
be transformed in the renewing of your minds and put off the old self and put
on the new self, imitate God, have a mind like Christ.
And even Jesus said, we need to worship God with all of our heart,
with all of our soul,
with all of our mind, and with all of our strength.
It's clear throughout Scripture that logic has a place and that is a tool that
shouldn't
be considered a threat.
In fact, it's an incredibly useful tool.
I mean, after all, Jesus said it and in fact,
you'll find the Bible study this week that
Jesus even demonstrated it.
We'll see a couple of strange things throughout the study and one of those things is
this
weird term that you see in Latin called reductio ad absurdum.
I'll say that again, reductio ad absurdum.
And essentially, it's just a fancy Latin word that means reduce to absurdity.
It's that simple and even that seems kind of confusing.
So let me give you an example that should help with your students to explain this
kind
of strange concept.
When I was a kid, ever so often I would skip school and this one time in particular
my dad caught me.
So naturally he asks me, why did you skip school?
I had this genius idea, this genius logic that I came up with and I told him, well,
all
my friends were doing it so that's why I did it.
That makes sense.
That made perfect sense in my head and I kind of stood there waiting for him to make
a
response and he didn't take very long before he said, well,
if all of your friends jumped
off a bridge, would you too?
Essentially what my dad was doing, whether he realized it or not,
was taking my argument,
drawing it out to its natural conclusion, which is absurd.
And that's essentially what reductio ad absurdum is telling us.
And when we see Matthew 22 is Jesus engaging in the same sort of logical analysis in
case
confrontation with the Pharisees.
So instead of fearing logic,
our goal is to get students to embrace logic and actually
get them to understand that logic is a vital tool in the search for truth.
Remember what we're doing here throughout this process and we talked about this.
We talked about truth is that students are looking for what is true.
We want students at the end of this process to be able to look truth squarely in the
face and actually see Jesus.
So logic is going to help them get to that point.
So in their intro experience,
we want them first to actually see that in their relationships.
So students are using logic in their relationships to search for truth in those
relationships
and we want them to do the same thing with Jesus.
So take Paul, for example.
If you look through Acts, whether Paul's in Corinth, whether he's in Ephesus,
whether
Paul's in Thessalonica or in Athens,
what you see is that Paul is constantly using logic.
He's reasoning from the Scriptures about helping them understand who Jesus is,
what he's all
about, what salvation means.
Essentially Paul uses logic through and through in almost every single one of his
arguments
as he's traveling on his missionary journeys.
So the idea is we want to invite students into a space where they can be curious and
not only ask the questions but sort of logically think through these things and add
an intellectual
piece to their faith.
So as you dive into small group,
you're going to ask what looks like a really simple question.
Should faith make sense?
That's kind of tricky, right?
There's a little bit going on here that we need to address because there's so
much about Jesus that does not seem to make sense.
There's so much about our faith that doesn't seem to make sense sometimes.
But as we think through, as we use logic,
as we actually engage intellectually with our
faith, there's a lot we can figure out and God has given us the tools to do so.
And really this is much of the Pharisees' problem, this is what we see from our
question one and their motivation to get after Jesus.
And they just didn't really get it.
But I want to take a second and really touch on question three because this deals
with potential
arguments against Christianity and whether or not these arguments make sense.
Be careful here but answer these honestly or talk about these honestly because there
are some arguments out there that sound pretty good that seem to make some sense.
But that doesn't mean that they're logical and doesn't make them right.
It just makes them additional arguments.
But a lot of them are worth talking about.
But make sure, gauge your students, make sure you know where they're at.
If you don't think your students can handle it,
then that may be a question you might want
to sidestep for just a minute and then come back to it when you think that they're
ready.
So as students depart for this week, leave them with this question.
What about your faith doesn't make sense to you?
And challenge them with what it's going to take to spur them on to a mature faith.
Because remember, Jesus calls us all to clear and careful thinking,
the same kind of thinking
that Jesus demonstrated.